ils sont 27 lauréats des entrepreneurs
accompagnés par le réseau entreprendre
yvelines réunis pour célébrer cette
promotion des 1018 au quotidien en fait
on a on a un programme mensuel
d'accompagnement est donc un non membre
chef d'entreprise la plupart du temps en
activité les suit au mois le mois pour
revoir avec eux d'une façon je dirais
effet miroir
quels sont les problèmes qui est ce qui
pourrait y avoir comme solution mais
jamais jamais jamais on prend la
décision à leur place c'est eux qui
prennent la décision
un parcours d'accompagnement entre deux
et trois ans pour des projets très
variés
thème de la soirée pensée ambitions j'ai
toujours eu cette envie de partir d'une
idée pour arriver jusqu'à voilà la
réalisation des clauses de concret à
vendre des idées qui nécessite du temps
après trois années de recherche et
développement le réseau et des mama fall
ignames à commercialiser son système de
complémentaire santé pour les proches de
la diaspora africaine est resté au
continu un ami avec qui je travaillais
un copain ingénieurs il a perdu sa maman
qui souffre d'un cancer parce qu'elle ne
pouvait pas effectuer étaient sur place
et là c'était le déclic il fallait faire
quelque chose et nous avons pensé
accueillez diaspora santé lancée en 2018
sa plateforme est déjà utilisé dans 13
pays différents
moi je trouve qu'il ya une génération
d'entrepreneurs et d'entrepreneur re au
féminin exceptionnelle qui a envie de
changer le monde qui écriront une
ambition pas seulement pour eux pas
seulement pour gagner de l'argent qui
même plus là le premier moteur de la
création d'entreprise pour
le réseau entreprendre yvelines fêtera
ses 10 ans en octobre prochain
il contribue à la création d'emplois
dans le département